je suis bien ouais je peux faire le
sergent-chef bien sûr j'adore
j'aime bien il est tout mignon le pont
excuse-moi cyril j'ai rien préparé ce
que je peux faire le singe c'est ce que
j'ai fait je me suis beaucoup j'ai
beaucoup regardé mais j'adore jésus est
jumelée
[Rires]
le chien a ici ça fait de vous m'excite
nixon a toujours eu un côté chienne lui
calme qu'est ce qu'il va faire enfin de
cris de l'otarie attention chez vous
attendez si vous mettez l'ontario
confessionnal pour la battre c'est
shining tabac c'est cochon qu'on égorge
moi c'est bien ca fait otaries et cochon
qu'on égorge péri
le cas est fou sur les connais le gars
est fou